I met a traveller from an antique land
who said two vast and trunkless legs of
stone stand in the desert near them on
the sand half sunk a shattered visage
lies whose frown and wrinkled lip and
sneer of cold command tell that it's
sculptor well those passions read which
yet survive stamped on these lifeless
things the hand that mocked them and the
heart that fed and on the pedestal these
words appear my name is Ozymandias king
of kings look on my works ye mighty and
despair nothing beside remains round the
decay of that colossal wreck boundless
and bare the lone and level sands
stretch far away so this is a poem
called Ozymandias written by a poet
percy bysshe shelley in the in the early
19th century some of the language may
seem a bit old-fashioned but it's held
up pretty well over the years and we're
going to use it today to talk about a
second form of invention and call it
right in college writing around the
notions of recall and reflect and this
has this is a kind of writing you do
typically in literature classes art
classes sometimes when you're doing
personal essays you're writing about
your own autobiography and you're trying
to figure out in all of the experiences
you've had which are the ones that are
important that you have that give you
clues to new learnings about yourself or
about what it is to be a human being and
this is kind of at the center of the
whole journey of the humanities which is
to get deeper and deeper into your
understanding of who you are as a person
and and how you you interact with
society and the various institutions
that we all live them up so we're here
with the Sal and I are going to do an
experiment here where I'm going to ask
cell to do some some recalling and
reflecting in relation to this poem but
before I say anything just overall
reaction to the poem as I was reading at
any particular reaction yeah you know I
like it it if I if I
it's kind of my understanding or my
impression is is right i mean it kind of
talks about something that you know i
always like to you know talk to my
friends and family about is you know
there's this whole notion of people
being obsessed with their kind of their
their achievements in the near term and
and their kind of ego gratification but
it's you know or we're all these little
animals on this little planet and where
we have a very small lifespan and we're
going to go away and that that stuff is
kind of silly in the schema is the
bigger things okay and this by the way i
would visualize get from this is burning
man so i'm thinking about you somebody
ought to like put this statue out at
Burning Man 1 year and it sort of sort
of has interesting when I see this I
actually think of like Wall Street well
I think of kind of the power brokers or
politicians and I think of kind of how
how they view their world today versus
what it really will be in the long term
yeah by the way when you said that to me
the other thing that just called in my
mind were the Oracle cylinders as we
drive up my name is king of kings
whatever okay well okay should I so
here's here's the kind of a when when
you have a poem like this you say well
okay so my teacher the class assignment
is to write something about this problem
where would I start so I like to ask
people to do is to pick out you just
close your eyes don't look at the poem
itself just thinking about as you heard
it what's the first detail in the poem
that comes to mind if my eyes are closed
right now I know people can't see me but
they are genuinely closed and if I
remember you know I there was kind of
this and you know I breakthrough kind of
these these two trunks and the sand and
and we're kind of in this very desolate
environment just is kind of what my
memory of kind of how was all starting
got you keep your eyes closed again
another another detail from the poem
just a second one that comes to mind and
then it starts talking about something
kind of laying in the sand and and my
brain was like is this as a person is
this a is the thing I at first started
to imagine it was a person to person or
thing got you okay anything else from
the poem that comes to mind
the the broken visitor of something I
remember that that word in particular
yet and yeah I mean tho those are kind
of okay literate let's use those three
things okay so so as you're looking at
those three things you let's circle like
let's circle them on the poem so this so
to vet that one caught you two vast and
trunkless legs cells and trunkless legs
of stone I didn't actually capture this
out well then it took a stay with what
you actually captured that yeah okay so
just just just just oseph you capture
and then you the second thing you said
something between lifeless things and
was like I saw this a half slug shadow
ridge okay okay shatters lies get that
one okay and on this part I was like
what are they talking about is it a
thing a person who knows and then and
then yeah the shattered village that was
those okay okay and then and then I
under lied lifeless things because you
said you didn't know as a person or a
thing and the course by that time it's
pretty clear that it's a thing yeah
although wasn't interesting maybe not
well by the time I got to the by the
time we started talking about the
pedestal where the words because I may
be a dead body ok Anderson came but okay
yes by the time I was a pedestal these
words and I kind of understood okay so
what's interesting so if we look at this
thing we say okay what is it about that
those images that you think is striking
um I guess having random just kind of
having a random object in the in kind of
this desert is almost more lonely than
just a desert yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay so sober it object in the
desert right okay I mean you can't be
lonely if they're if there's no there's
nothing there right if it's just a
desert there's no there's no but yes
it's just there's this one thing
standing in the desert so high so we
talked to you I asked you your first
reaction you're reacting a lot to the
bottom half of the poem how does the
idea of lonely relate to the bottom half
of the palm in your mind well you know
it's it's a you know
the tire you know from the from the pub
poems point of view you know there's
just this relic is sitting here at the
desert and it's and it's you know it's
clearly just just a trace of this maybe
once great civilization and and and
there's this irony that on that relic is
written my name is Ozymandias king of
kings and this is it this isn't some of
the small ego right he's I just an King
he's the king of kings look on my works
ye mighty and despair like how
intimidating am I like I'm a big deal uh
and and and so there at one point this
is evidence of this may be great Empire
this egotistical king who thought he was
almost a god and and but it shows how
how futile his his his words were and
how how silly they seemed from the
perspective of now okay so I think I
think I and that's clearly I think
that's exactly what I'm pretty sure
that's what the effect Shelley wanted to
create so now you say okay but Shelley
wrote this poem and 18 I don't know plus
1810 see that's within 10 years of being
right it sits nice 2013 I mean why do we
care why do you care what why does this
touch you because because these are
still kind of themes that are alive in
our world am you you see people who are
very much driven by empire I mean the
eighteen hundreds was a period literally
of empire for the for the world and so
he but but but the but the but but today
you still have people kind of blind
lessly pursuing Empire and and kind of
end and numbers and money you know and
as you say you don't you don't take a
moving truck to your grave yes right you
the bank but but you may it's
interesting that we've relocated it so
this was in a political military sphere
you and I both intuitively relocated it
to Silicon Valley and and frankly at
least I i internalized that to the tech
industry in particular and the financial
services industry those were the two
that we've been you were in financial
services right hello both I mean yeah I
terraced and then I worked in finance
and I mean I I tend to give a tech a
little bit more of a free pass because I
do think that especially Silicon Valley
is more focused with impacted innovation
that necessarily Empire and legacy
while you know is not all I mean this is
these are shoes no you're sure sure sure
I'll balance people in the financial
world but a lot of what you see I mean
even though you know when you go to the
place like New York you see the
skyscrapers and these are I mean these
are really these are really kind of
shrines to ego yeah I don't have to hate
that's all yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
I think it's great and it to meet so the
shattered village for me is the exact
it's the it's a face which would be a
person but it's broken and it's in stone
and it's in the sand and it is that it's
that image of what ego can do to
personality I mean it will if you freeze
on ego and don't let it kind of turns
you into a lifeless thing at least that
now that may be that may not be that's
probably me or meditate but so so what
we're doing here and let going to bring
this to a close is so there's a poem
here it created an impression when you
listen to a Palmer will see a work of
art you get an impression and part of
what the the exercise of literary
criticism or artistic criticism is to
recall the impression by coming back
with the details that stand out most in
your mind they're the ones that somehow
our key to the depth of the impression
and then just just speculating about
them to say what does that mean to me
what can I learn about myself or about
this experience that I didn't know
before and and and then use that so let
me just ask you as a way of closing if
you had to step back for this and say
this poem obviously confirmed a number
of things you felt is there anything
about the poem you said well but i don't
know that i looked at it that way quite
that way before is there something i
learned from this problem specifically
or is this poem or just one more example
of something i already knew I think you
very I mean it it's very in line with
kind of how I often kind of you know
when I get self-righteous with my
friends ebook allow hip take out
Ozymandias hey just read it too okay
wants dinner now yeah I mean but you
know it's it I think it has a power to
it that you know just saying like why
are you look you know we can talk with
our friends over over you know coffee
and say hey you know why are we really
here and why are we pursuing
this material stuff and why are we so
concerned about our titles and our
position in our power and all of that
but i think i think you know poem like
this has a nice way of really putting it
in perspective that's great okay